what has prompted China's iron handed
approach in Xinjiang if you believe a
leak of government documents it was the
words from this man Chinese President Xi
Jinping he allegedly ordered officials
to show court absolutely no mercy when
dealing with terrorism and separatism in
Xinjiang the result of that has been up
to a million Weaver's interned in
detention camps like this one families
separated and the destruction of weaker
culture by raising mosques and other
religious heritage heritage in the
region in a moment I'll speak to someone
who's experienced the uncertainty of
separation from their family but first
here's more on what is contained in
these revelations a city in harmony and
joy under the watch of Big Brother human
rights organizations and the UN have
long suggested that scenes like this are
all for show and that families here are
suffering under a crackdown from Beijing
but details had been scarce now a major
leak has provided an unprecedented view
into what the Chinese government calls
vocational training centers in Xinjiang
the New York Times says it obtained four
hundred pages of internal Communist
Party documents some of which tells Xin
Jiang officials how to explain the
disappearance of parents and families to
Weger college students returning home on
school breaks officials are advised to
say that there in schools to undergo
retraining your relatives had been
infected by the virus of Islamic
radicalism and must be quarantined and
cured treasure-wish chance for free
education that the party and government
has provided to thoroughly eradicate
erroneous thinking and also learn
Chinese and job skills I'm sure that you
will support them because this is for
their own good and also for your own
good the directive also advises shinjang
officials to tell students not to
believe or spread rumors that could
affect how long their relatives will be
detained
the catalyst for the current ongoing
clampdown has his roots a decade ago
when there was a surge in
anti-government protests and ethnic
violence by wiggers in 2014
Chinese President Xi Jinping reportedly
delivered a series of internal speeches
following a visit to Shin Jung setting a
hard-line course he reportedly said
Beijing had to be as harsh on what he
called extremists and show quote
absolutely no mercy but the report says
she also rejected proposals to eliminate
Islam in the country Beijing did not
deny the authenticity of the documents
but described the report as a clumsy
patchwork of selective interpretation
the New York Times used dubious tactics
of changing context and taking meaning
out of context to publicize so-called
internal documents China will never be
soft in its fight against violent
terrorists and it will spare no effort
in protecting the safety of its people's
lives and that means near complete
surveillance enhanced with AI facial
recognition and data analytics
monitoring whether the people of Shin
Jung are putting approved thoughts and
actions about family ties Baram santosh
is a weaker researcher and joins me on
the line from washington d.c Barham
welcome what do you make of the
revelations that Chinese authorities are
taking a hard-line approach in Xinjiang
so this time and it the level of this
persecution is worse than what has
happened in 60s for example the masses
were not demolished in that time and now
our demos so means this time China also
detained millions of people in and holds
them in camps so in the 60s this never
happened so my father also experienced
the first
in 60s cultures evolution time so now
he's experiencing this again in the camp
so so I'm so sad because of he's a age
of 70s and he's being on punishing by a
government in-camera what has that done
to you or your family not having heard
from your father who's 70 years old for
the past two years how do you cope with
that uncertainty so it's hard kind of
feeling that it is common feeling for
all the egos in the aspera so we
couldn't contact with our family members
this is very hard for us and this is the
kind of feeling that someone kidnap you
load once in the you don't have
information about them so you worry
about your logo on every day so daily
basis so only thing we can do at the
moment to raise our voice to tell the
world what is happening in the legal
religion and we've been kill the work at
last two years so now is the kind of
word now one more step to trying to
understand what is happening in the
region so people have to know that those
those are crimes against humanity also
to the Ignatian like leaguers as soon as
possible and take their action to save
us Baram you spoke of raising your voice
do you think the world is listening to
that voice and acting on it yeah I think
in the Western world like American you
know now is giving more attention to
Eagle cries so this is good also in the
u.s. US politics and the government that
all day also close attention and the
concerns about the Eagles Christ in the
individual region so now but is but the
Islamic world our silence on what is
happening in the wiggle region also they
supported China
change our policy and as they just they
don't we go in even their media's zito
cover up at the group right so this is
this is very horrific because what is
happening in the region is that crime
against Islam in in the Islam Islamic
history so this never happened in
Islamic history no government demolished
more than 10,000 most and burn legal
crowns and a frame s and D tainted
millions of Muslims in Turkey and
denounced them the religion also falsely
let some eat the pork and believe in a
Chinese government and his chichi
fetuses this is crime against Islam and
also work
Baram Santosh thank you very much for
speaking to us